si la parole est à monsieur jean
frédéric poisson merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues avant de poser ma
question à monsieur mise d'agriculture
je voudrais faire part de mon étonnement
celui d'un certain nombre de mes
collègues de notre groupe avoir entendu
la réponse du secrétaire d'état en
charge des relations avec le parlement
sur cette affaire de la mosquée de saint
martin d'hères de deux choses l'une
monsieur le secrétaire d'état ou bien
mes collègues georges fenech et olivier
falorni sont mal informés et ils mentent
ou alors votre réponse l'exemple est
l'incarnation de l'inaction du
gouvernement en la matière en ce qui me
concerne je penche pour la deuxième
solution
le seul ministre de l'agriculture il ya
quelques jours le principal syndicat
d'exploitants agricoles vous demander de
reporter la date à laquelle les
exploitants agricoles doivent déposer
leur demande d'être pour la pac 2016
ils l'ont fait pour une raison simple
c'est que au moment où il s'apprête à
solliciter de l'union européenne via
l'intermédiaire de l'état les aides au
titre de la politique agricole commune
premièrement les dossiers des aides 2015
ne sont pas soldés et deuxièmement le
renseignement des dossiers de l'aide
2016 sont d'une complexité telle que ni
les services de l'état ne sont capables
de faire face ni effectivement les
agriculteurs eux mêmes ne sont capables
de renseigner correctement ses dossiers
et donc monsieur le ministre à la crise
sans précédent que connaît le monde
agricole s'ajoute aujourd'hui une très
grande inquiétude une très grande
interrogation de beaucoup d'exploitants
qui ne connaissent toujours pas l'état
exact de leurs comptes 2015 et qui sont
dans l'incapacité d'opérer les bons
choix stratégiques pour leur
exploitation en 2016 le malaise
administratif et l monsieur le ministre
que dans beaucoup d'endroits les
directions départementales en charge de
ces dossiers ont posé le crayon purement
et simplement des normes sionisme à
question est double quelles dispositions
allez vous prendre pour que ces dossiers
puissent être remplies en temps et en
heure avant le 30 juin
et deuxièmement qu'avez vous fait pour
simplifier les démarches administratives
sous lesquels croulent les exploitations
agricoles r6 la parole les tablettes et
stéphane le foll ministre de
l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et de
la forêt
je débutais ce président je vais pas
revenir sur la question préalable que
vous avez posé qui s'adressait à
monsieur le ministre des relations avec
le parlement mais je vais revenir sur le
sujet que vous évoquez sur les
agriculteurs la première chose c'est que
je le rappelle si nous sommes en retard
c'est que nous avons été obligés de
refaire ce qu'on appelle un registre
parcellaire graphique de l'ensemble des
parcelles agricoles françaises suite je
le dis quand même au passage à ce qu'on
appelle un apurement européen qui fait
que la france a été sanctionné à hauteur
de 1 milliard d'euros pour des erreurs
sur des versements dead avant 2012
c'est le premier point deuxième point
ray vous plaît allez allez ce retard qui
a été prise suite à cette remise en
place d'un nouveau parcellaire graphique
a été compensée par des versements dead
anticipé en 2015 à la fois en octobre
avec des avances et le sol en 2000 enfin
en décembre 2015
et pour ce qui est de l'année 2016 on
aura donc la mise en place de télépathe
qui s'est fait le 1er avril avec ses
surfaces non agricoles qui ont été près
dessinée et qui sont aujourd'hui dans
les dossiers de chaque agriculteur pour
lui faciliter le travail et faire en
sorte qu'il n'est qu'à corriger ce qu'il
considère être une erreur par rapport à
ce qu'ils sont parcellaires
voilà ce qu'on a fait et qu'en même
temps que ce travail sera fait et les
aides 2015 et les aides 2016 seront
versés et que pour l'instant
contrairement à ce qu'a demandé le
président de la fnsea qui m'a accueilli
d'ailleurs chaleureusement à laval je
considère que le processus est en cours
et que pour l'instant il n'y a pas à
remettre en cause la date à laquelle il
devrait être fini je rappellerai
simplement monsieur poisson qui a un
débat qui agite beaucoup votre
opposition sur le nombre de
fonctionnaires regardez bien supprimé
plus de 500 mille fonctionnaires
regardez ce que ça peut avoir comme
concert comme conséquences sur
l'agriculture en particulier
merci la parole